[Musique]
nous avons été alertés par un certain
nombre d'articles de presse qui
faisaient état de difficultés dans ce
fond Marianne ce que cherche à
comprendre la commission des finances
c'est le fonctionnement les crédits
alloués puis la répartition des crédits
voire comment tout cette organisé quelle
séquence comment les choix sont opérés
nous avons commencé avec le secrétaire
général et le secrétaire général adjoint
du comité interministériel qui gère
l'ensemble de ses fonds maintenant nous
allons poursuivre en auditionnant un
certain nombre d'associations qui ont
bénéficié de ces fonds les cabinets des
ministres concernés et puis nous
conclurons par l'audition des deux
ministres en charge celles qui a créé le
fond et puis celle qu'on a eu comment
dire le contrôle
après avoir été nommé par le
gouvernement nous avons besoin
simplement de nous assurer que tout a
été fait dans les règles le fond
Marianne pour les Français c'est pas la
question uniquement de savoir comment
ont été utilisés 2 millions d'euros dans
le budget de la France mais la question
elle est très symbolique on imagine pas
mais de gens considèrent que moralement
il est important de savoir comment se
font a été utilisé les Français
aujourd'hui veulent la clarté sur ce
sujet il y a un travail important nous
allons le faire dans un délai que nous
avons choisi un délai resserré puisque
c'est en moins de trois mois que nous
aurons rendu nos conclusions
[Musique]